good morning Hank it's Tuesday so well
my favorite youtubers CGP grey link in
the doobly-doo recently did a video
debunking 10 popular misconceptions this
inspired me to want to debug more
misconceptions
for instance number one the Quran says
all martyrs get 72 virgins in heaven
yeah the Quran doesn't say that that
tradition comes from a hadith which are
collections of sayings of the Prophet
Muhammad and that particular Heath is
really poorly sourced it's like I heard
from a guy who talked to a guy and his
cousin was all like that the Prophet had
said like 72 virgins or something
furthermore Hank there are some people
who argue that the word virgins is being
mistranslated here and that the actual
translation is like white grapes
misconception number two 0.999 repeating
is less than one in fact point nine nine
nine repeating is equal to one which you
know because 0.333 repeating is equal to
1/3 and 1/3 plus 1/3 plus 1/3 is one
misconception number 3 ostriches buried
their head in the sand to hide from
predators seem correct they bury their
heads in the sand because they have to
dig nests and they don't have hands with
which to dig misconception number 4
sharks don't get cancer so you should
eat shark to keep yourself from getting
cancer in fact sharks do get cancer
although we don't know how often because
everyone is always killing them
misconception number 5 there is an edge
to the universe so hint during the last
week of our tour you became obsessed
with the fact that there is no edge to
the universe but instead of saying you
like that you just kept saying dude no
edge and you kept accusing me of being
in adequately fascinated about the lack
of edges in the universe when in fact it
was your portrayal of this fact that was
so annoying to me because you just be
like eating a sandwich or something and
you turn to me and be like hey John
there is no edge but anyway yes
apparently there is no edge to the
universe I still don't understand how
that works but I'm sure that you will
explain it to me
misconception number six Albert Einstein
failed mathematics no he did it to
Albert Einstein was really really good
at mathematics in fact to quote him
before I was 15 I had mastered
differential calculus misconception
number 7 Al Gore claimed to have
invented the Internet
no he didn't he claimed to have taken
the initiative in creating the Internet
which is also an exaggeration but just
not not the same exaggeration that
people accuse him of misconception
number 8 late in the winter of your 17th
year you are 17 no late in the winter of
your first year you are still zero late
in the winter of your second year you
are 1 and late in the winter of your
17th year you are 16 misconception
number 9 humans have five senses wrong
humans have way more than five senses
the five senses were identified by
Aristotle and here's a little rule of
thumb Aristotle while he is very famous
and everything is almost always wrong in
addition to the five senses we all know
you can also sense relative temperature
which is called thermo ception you can
sense body and limb position and you can
sense balance which is called
equilibrium you can also sense the need
to go deeper which is called Inception
sorry I apologize I apologize to my
whole family for that misconception
number 10 George Washington had wooden
dentures snow alas his dentures were far
more disturbing than that they were made
of gold lead hippopotamus ivory dead
people teeth and donkey teeth link in
the doobly-doo to the original video
also to Michael Rhonda's brilliant video
of Hank saying no edge over and over
again also have you seen our new show
crash course we're teaching you about
stuff here's a preview the test will
measure whether you are an informed
engaged and productive citizen of the
world and it will take place in schools
and bars and hospitals and dorm rooms
and in places of worship the test will
judge your ability to think about things
other than celebrity marriages whether
you'll be easily persuaded by empty
political rhetoric and whether you'll be
able to place your life and your
community in a broader context the test
will last your entire life and it will
be comprised of the millions of
decisions that when taken together make
your life yours and everything
everything will be on
panco you're feeling better don't forget
to be awesome I will see you on Friday